les suites de la démission de Jean
Gandois le débat sur les 35 heur s'est
déplacé aujourd'hui à l'Assemblée
nationale l'occasion pour le Premier
ministre de dire qu'il ne reviendrait
pas sur son engagement électoral sur
place Michel l MERER Jean-Jacques butier
à l'Assemblée
nationale s'il vous plaît s'il vous
plaît un peu de silence l'irruption du
social dans la politique aujourd'hui à
l'Assemblée d'emblé l'opposition montit
clairement sa volonté d'en découdre sur
les suites de la Conférence nationale et
sur les 35h la France s'il vous plaît
détient à la fois le temps de travail le
plus bas et le nombre de chômeurs le
plus haut de de la plupart des grands
pays
industrialisé votre politique va
conduire à une hémorragie d'emploi vers
nos compétiteurs européens monsieur le
Premier ministre nous sommes sur les 35
heur à contrecourant du monde regrettait
l'opposition nous ne sommes pas
contrecourant du monde nous sommes à
contrecourant de
l'ultralibéralisme le
gouvernementose j un rôle moteur en
Europe et puis Pla de Lionel Jospin
c'était nos engagements et le
gouvernement entend bien les respecter
il vous est arrivé de mener campagne sur
un slogan qui avait intéressé le peuple
et qui était la lutte contre la fracture
sociale vous avez abandonné ce slogan
vous avez été sanctionné pour cela si je
dois un jour être sanctionné par le
peuple je préfère que ce soit sur ma
politique que sur l'abandon de ma
politique deè polémique l'oosition tente
de faire porter au chef du gouvernement
la responsabilité de la démission du
patron du cnvf qui aurait été dupé je
c'est le reniment et c'est je casse tout
c'est le peuple français qui choisit son
gouvernement c'est le gouvernement qui
dirige et conduit la politique de la
nation et pas le CNP Martin au est
néanmoins prête à prendre le Paris en
dépit de la position du CNPF les patrons
négocieront au sein des
entreprises